let me talk about Alex Jones right who I
have a bit of history with each other to
get me deported from the United States
did he yeah what is your view of Alex
Jones I think that Alex Jones is a
sovereign individual who very much like
the Rabid left deserves a chance to
speak on his points of view I think that
the truth on issues is usually somewhere
in the middle between two extremes and I
think do you think Sandy Hook was staged
I don't know anything about Sandy Hook
really you know he's just been sued by
the families for millions and millions I
have no idea you don't know anything
about it no so why would you support
someone in public you know nothing about
the most infamous when have I supported
him in public you have supported him in
public I've been on his podcast yeah but
you said nice things about him I say
nice things about lots of people what do
you think about it I said nice things
about you pierce that's fine
so to sit and say that I've been on a
podcast and I say nice things about it
you said you support you support his
right to speak about things like Sandy
Hook I don't know Sandy Hook I don't
know and he know what it was it was a
mass shooting of school children okay
but to sit and and he's actually no no
let's stop for a second please don't
interrupt me the here's why you're I
know why you're good at your job first
you interrupt people a lot which is good
it's a good skill so you're right and
then there you go prove me right the
timing is good here's exactly what I did
I only interrupt people like you when
you either
refuse to answer the question or answer
a completely different one sure and I
want to remind you of what the question
was or when you misquote me back which
you've done repeatedly through the
interview where you say you see peers
you agree with me and the viewer who's
been watching will go no he didn't cool
no problem the other thing you do is you
try and set these traps like now so
you're saying what's the Trap you think
I'm saying it you're saying that I agree
with every single point of view a man
has I literally didn't say that you're
saying well you support Alex Jones why
don't you misquote me because you're
saying you support Alex Jones and you
said he you've been on his podcast and
he said this
I don't know what do you think about
exchange I don't know everything he said
what do you think of him I think I think
on his podcast he was cordial I think he
was professional on his podcast I've
also done podcasts with rabid leftists
and and people who openly hate me is it
wrong I do a podcast circuit so and I
don't know everything he's ever said
when somebody like I don't know what so
I don't know what you're trying to say
get me here because I didn't get a word
in edgewise I'll tell you it's pretty
it's a it's a lame trick if you let me
get a word in I will tell you let's go
Alex Jones said that Sandy Hook didn't
happen it was staged by actors okay this
compounded the appalling grief of the
families of those poor 20 children okay
who were gunned to Pieces by a lunatic
with an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle they
were already Greek strict and beyond
belief and this guy pulled petrol onto
that grief quite deliberately to make a
huge amount of money from his Infowars
fake news [ __ ] and as a result a lot
of the families have now sued him and
they've won and he's gonna have to pay
back tens maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars in damages to these families and
quite right it won't do anything about
the pain he calls them some of them
actually have people turn up outside
their houses with guns because Alex
Jones had told them that these parents
were making it all up they were all
staged actors it was all run by the
government so I simply say to you now
I've told you that what is your view of
Alex Jones
I don't see why any of that has to do
with me I I it's very interesting I've
done the guys podcast I know him well he
was professional and courteous to me
when I meet somebody and they show me
respect I show them back respect that's
what I do as I did with you you respect
him I if somebody shows me respect I
show them respect so I don't know I
don't know if Hitler shows you respect
you'd respect him back if that that's a
stupid question it's not it's a
logically extension of your argument no
if in 1931 I was walking through Germany
and a man come up to me and said sorry
for bumping into you I'd say sorry no
problem eh I'd show respect that I don't
know what are you trying to say I
sanctioned the Holocaust he literally
just said if somebody respects you you
respect them back I say if somebody
shows me respect I show respect back
that's a good way to go through life
whoever it is if somebody shows me
respect and is courteous to me I'm
curious back I didn't respect somebody
who caused such misery and pain to sound
I have no idea the specifics of the
thing you're discussing I don't
understand any of it well I don't know
anything about it when you've told me
your version of events when did you go
on the podcast
I was on the podcast about four or four
times in the last four years I did one
relatively recently it's a full-time
four times you went on Alex Jones's
podcast correct promoting him helping
him making I think he was promoting and
helping him because what is his podcast
well yeah but I've been on the podcast
of people who absolutely hate me I've
been a liberal left-wing podcast I've
been a feminist and no you just sat here
saying I'm I'm I would like you to agree
perhaps we can agree on this point that
I'm not a feminist I go on feminist
podcasts I do a podcast circuit I do not
feminist I don't know what do you think
your feminist is well let's not change
subject here Pierce stay on the side you
mentioned feminism completely but you're
trying to you see you're trying to get
away from the point because what you did
is you're trying to say because I did a
podcast I sanctioned all this person's
views and I'm saying I do five podcasts
a week I do five podcasts a week and I
don't sanction 100 of the views of any
other person on the planet because I'm
an individual and he has an individual
views as do you so I don't know why
you're trying to come at me with one of
his views and pretend that's something
it's a pretty big view no but it's it's
a lame trick peers and you're better
than this so let's move on would you
explain it
had a podcast would you on it sure you
would great okay let me know what you're
talking about Vladimir Putin had a
podcast to go on it if Joe Biden had a
podcast I'd go on it if a feminist has a
podcast will go on it it appears Morgan
has a podcast I'll go on it if Alex
Jones I mean I don't see the point
you're making there's no point here
you're just you're digging but there's
nothing to find well I'm not I'm taking
your position that if somebody shows you
respect you respect them I think that
I'm saying there are lots of people in
the world I do not respect if Vladimir
Putin showed me in respect I would not
respect him but that's your opinion but
no it's my view okay that's your view
well your still view is you would you're
sitting here peers saying that I'm on
uncensored show and in your intro you
said that it's important that we don't
have Echo Chambers and we have very
correct and that we have varying
opinions right but then you're saying
the people you don't like you wouldn't
go on their podcast no no so you are a
hypocrite no no I will go on anybody's
podcast
I don't think you understand what
censorship means do you like a lot of
words we've had problems with today
you're just saying you what you're doing
censorship means no but the point I'm
trying to make here you know what you
think censorship means don't hide from
the fact that you're saying you will
only do podcasts with people you like
why do you think that's censorship now
that's your that's your prerogative My
Prerogative is I'll just stay with
censorship I'll discuss I'll discuss
opinions with anybody and I've done hard
left-wing why are you not asking me
about the podcast I've done for the
people who are hard liberal by the way I
don't care whether they're left or right
extremists to me uh all nuts right then
we agree yes so perfect good next
subject all right here's my next subject
it's a very serious case here Jesus and
before we move on sorry Pierce but
before we move on I do find it kind of
disingenuous and I know we're on a show
and and I don't have a personal problem
with you but it is kind of disingenuous
to try and sit here and lump me in with
something with some school shooting
that's nothing to do with me I was
that's nothing to do I mean on any level
let me respond any level let me explain
like you've just said you've been on
this podcast four times in four years
since he said the whole thing was staged
I don't know and I simply and I think
the fact that a smart guy like you wants
me to believe you had no idea that Alex
Jones who's been in the news now for the
last two years have been sued by these
families for the most heinous thing
imaginable of pouring petrol onto their
grief by claiming that shooting was
staged the fact that you're pretending
you didn't know about any of that it's
not about pretending you've been on
being on his podcast four times
supporting him and making him money so
damn right I'm going to call you out
when I do a podcast if you think I spend
time analyzing the point of view that
every that of that person and everything
they've ever said for years beforehand
so years it was minutes years and years
you were trying to lump me in and attack
me for a person whose podcast I do
having a view is absolutely childish
because because I've done a bunch of
podcasts I've done a bunch of podcasts
with people who are advocating for
things okay that I do not agree with on
every single level in fact most of my
podcasts are me disagreeing with people
so it's completely crazy that you're
trying to lump me in with that that's
cheap that's cheap you are completely
misconstruing the point of what I'm
saying I think deliberately no no what
you're trying is a cheap trick and I'm
just making it clear I'm just curious
where you're like where your moral line
is it's a cheap trick I disagree with
the points of view with the majority of
the people I do podcast with so it's a
very cheap trick you're trying here so
people invent vile things to make
themselves rich off the back of families
of little kids who've been blown to
pieces with a machine gun
or a semi-automatic version of a machine
gun I think that is actually a line I
would I wouldn't cross I wouldn't be
happy to go on someone's podcast when
they've been responsible for doing that
it's not about political views or
differences of opinion over facts it's
about somebody deliberately inventing a
pack of lies to compound the grief of
families and I just I'm curious you
don't think you have any need to go down
any kind of moral quandary about people
like that before you continue to allow
them to use you for their own promotion
he didn't use me he didn't use me on the
podcast because we disagreed and
discussed points like we're doing with
you right now did you call him out on
that are you using me we didn't discuss
that I'm not using I'm giving you a
platform most people aren't giving you
right now to show the world who you
really are fantastic so neither of us
are using each other I'm here on your
show I'm providing you with content
you're giving me a platform and nobody's
using each other it's mutual we don't
agree on a whole bunch of issues it's
fine and here we are I think we've had a
robust exchange yeah just like I've done
on nearly every other podcast and for if
someone were to come and say say to me
in the future that something heaven
forbid there was a skeleton in your
closet and some were to come to me and
say you were on Piers Morgan's show did
you know he's ex or he's done X I would
say that's absolutely nothing to do with
right but I'm I make the same point
protecting you I don't I don't know what
you do I don't know your personal
guarantee I can guarantee one thing I
will not be inventing stories about I
have families I hope you I hope I hope
not I hope you're a righteous person but
I don't know me to be a righteous person
I don't know I'm just saying that I just
think it's interesting that you have no
moral compulsion about going on people
like moral compulsions it's about I
don't know what you do Pierce you could
have a bunch of skeletons in your closet
my friend I don't have a clue I'm here
on your TV show I'm sure we all have
lots of skeletons